-Welcome back to "Late Night".
We're here with Jonathan Majors.
Now you obviously have some
athletic experience.
I know you grew up in Texas,
you played basketball,
you played football.
But you also were a poet
at a young age.
-I was a poet at a young age.
-Yeah, and you had a poet name.
-Yes, the advent
of J. Manifesto.
-J. Manifesto.
-Yes.
-That is a very good poet name.
-Thank you.
-Especially for
Jonathan Majors, I think
that's a really good one.
-Same initials.
-Yep.
-I had it put on the back
of my letterman jacket.
-Wow.
-Yeah, it said "Manifesto".
I thought it was very artsy
and cool.
-Yeah, that's a real nice
combination of, like,
sports and arts.
-Jock.
-Yeah, a letterman jacket with
your poetry name on the back.
-There was the football.
There was my number
and then the mask.
-Oh, really? You had the, like,
the comedy and drama masks?
-Yeah, I had all the patches.
-That's great.
-And then it had "J. Manifesto"
on the back --
no, it had "Manifesto"
on the back.
-Yeah.
-And then I was expelled
two days after I got it.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-What were you expelled for?
-Psh! Everything.
-Yeah.
-Oh, they got you on everything
all at once?
-I was at Rico.
-[ Laughs ] Rico.
-Rico, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I gave it to my first love
who still has it.
-Really?
-Yeah, it's in a closet
someplace.
-That's -- oh, yeah, wow.
-Yeah, if I could get that back,
that'd be...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, first loves tend to check
out interviews with their,
you know, former amours.
-I reckon.
-Yeah.
You spent some --
You worked at --
before you were an actor
and, I guess,
after you were a poet --
you worked at a number of chains
we're familiar with.
Olive Garden, Starbucks,
Party City.
-Olive Garden, Starbucks,
-Red Lobster.
-Red Lobster, Quiznos Subs...
-Wow.
-...Braum's Ice Creamery...
-Okay.
-No, you don't know Braum's.
[ Laughter ]
You don't know Braum's.
-I will say it was said
like they knew.
-It was. I was like, "What?"
-It wasn't like one
of those loose "whoos".
It was like, "Yeah."
-Yeah, "Can I get the double
with the --"
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it was great, man.
Like, working
at a Halloween shop was cool.
You'd see costumes, you'd go,
"Oh, nice, interesting.
This person is playing Velma
from 'Scooby-Doo'."
And you're just thinking about
what that person's like,
you know, and you were like,
"Nice."
And then you work at Quiznos,
and all of a sudden,
you know, you're
an Italian sandwich man.
-Yeah.
-And carbonera, you know, you
really invest in --
[Italian accent] "Carbonera,"
[Normal voice] you know?
-So these were, in a way, you
were just taking them on as
roles before your bigger roles.
-Bro, I had to.
-Yeah.
-I was working maybe two
or three of them at a time.
-Gotcha.
-And still trying to do
the whole letterman thing.
-And then you were in
New York City for a brief
period of time, right?
-Then I went to North Carolina
School of the Arts,
another school.
[ Crowd cheers ]
-There you go, they knew it.
-Guys.
Yeah, she knew it.
-Pickles!
-Pickles? Okay, you're in.
You're in, you're in, you're in.
Yeah, and I worked here
in New York City.
I was following around a mentor
named Ruben Santiago-Hudson.
-Mm-hmm.
-And was trying to get
in his rehearsal room
as much as possible.
But I was also working
on Second Avenue,
and there was three bars
on Second Avenue --
two of them
which are still there --
and I worked at them.
I was the -- I played the role
of the bar-back...
-Uh-huh.
-...the host...
-Yeah.
-...the bouncer...
-So you could do it all?
-...the runner.
-Yeah.
-I mean, yeah, I was --
-When you came in wearing
that poetry-and-football jacket,
they were like, "I think he can
handle almost anything."
-Yeah, I could do everything.
-Do people -- especially, you
know, obviously, New York City,
you work in bars,
colorful characters,
but they're also
your colleagues --
do you hear from those people
still?
Are they proud of where
this has all ended up for you?
-Well, full circle, bro.
'Cause we chatted right before
I went to "SNL".
-That's right. We talked
right beforehand.
You were fantastic.
-Thank you.
-You're very welcome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-When I hit "SNL",
they blew me up.
For whatever reason, "SNL"
and those bars --
they were just like, "Oh,
my God, Jonathan, we knew.
This and that. Blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah."
Now it's like,
"Oh, love you guys."
-Yeah.
-So, yeah, like, we stay tight.
-That's wonderful.
-Yeah, these movies go up,
and I get pictures of Kang,
you know.
They send it to me, and I go,
"All love, man."
-Yeah, that's fantastic.
Well, no one ever expects when
they're, you know, working
with a bar-back, that one day
they're gonna be Kang.
You know, that's...
-True! True, true.
-That's true. They might think
you're gonna host "SNL",
but at the time --
-Kang.
-I think it's gonna be Kang.
-No, nobody thought that.
Nobody thought that.
-Now you have a 9-year-old
daughter.
Is there any of your work
that she's engaged with?
Is she impressed with her dad?
Or is this stuff a little...
-She's impressed when I throw
her very high...
-Oh, that's good.
-...and she lands on the bed.
-All right.
-Right now, she's having
a bit of a moment.
-Okay.
-My daughter's 9, almost 10.
-And recently [Sighs]
much to my chagrin,
young boys are walking up to her
and saying,
"You know, you look a lot
like Kang."
-Oh, wow.
-And my daughter looks at them
and goes, "That's my daddy."
[ Laughter ]
So she's dealing with that,
and, I mean, she was starstruck
by Paul Rudd.
-Yeah, well, who isn't?
-Fair point.
-Yeah, I mean,
all ages, all walks of life.
-Fair point, fair point,
fair point.
-Well, she has a lot to be
impressed about.
It is always so wonderful
to see you.
Thanks so much for being here.
-This is worth it, man.
Thank you.
-Congratulations on your films.
Congratulate Jonathan Majors.
"Creed III" in theaters
and IMAX tomorrow.
And "Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania" also out now.
Be right back with Riley Keough.